hello we're glad you've joined us for
this slide webinar the microbiome guts
brain access linking gastrointestinal in
neuro behavior processes and autism
spectrum disorder I am Christina mahalik
of libraries and I'll be moderating the
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by labyrinth the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning to learn more visit lab routes
comm let's get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them in the Q&A box which will open when
you click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green a Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C e button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits it is now my
pleasure to introduce today's speaker
dr. Ruth and Luna PhD in be ASCP cm
director of medical metagenomics texas
children's microbiome Center
assistant professor pathology and
immunology Baylor College of Medicine
dr. Ruth Ann Luna serves as assistant
professor in the Department of Pathology
in immunology a Baylor College of
Medicine and as director of the Medical
metagenomics within Texas Children's
microbiome Center at Texas Children's
Hospital dr. until dr. Luna directs the
next generation sequencing efforts of
the texas children's microbiome Center
and focuses on multi Helmick profiling
and a variety of body science and
disease populations
dr. Luna is a member of the
institutional review board of Baylor
College of Medicine and is active in
clinical research as principal
investigator of two ongoing studies she
is exploring the gastrointestinal and
our behavior aspects of children
diagnosed with autism autism spectrum
disorder ASD with specific emphasis on
gut microbiota in metabolize the impact
that antibiotic treatment on the core
symptoms of ASD once again it is my
pleasure to introduce dr. Luna dr. Luna
the floor is all yours
thank you for the introduction Christina
so to jump right in to quickly review
our objectives we're going to hopefully
explain the potential role of the
guttering axis in autism spectrum
disorder we're also going to describe
how changes in the microbiome may
correlate very strongly with changes in
the behavioral symptoms associated with
ASD and then finally we will identify
diagnostic and therapeutic potential of
microbiome characterization as well as
microbial manipulation in the treatment
of autism so our fascination with the
microbiome really started well over a
decade ago and this illustration
published in discover in 2007 depicts
our various current habitants of our
body at this point we were just
beginning to appreciate that we were
less human than we originally thought
with human cells only making up about
10% of the cells in our body and the
remainder of the cells being bacteria
fungi protists archaea and viruses sir
early on we also adopted this
fundamental concept that there was a
core human microbiome that was
influenced by a variety of factors
including lifestyle
environment even genetics but as the
science has evolved that core continues
to shrink as we've discovered more and
more variables that contribute to the
structure and the dynamic evolution of
our microbiomes so this shrinking core
microbiome is due in part to healthy or
normal looking very different depending
on your location in the world the
greatest degree of resolution can
actually be seen when diving deeper into
not just specific diseases but actual
subtypes within a disease population and
more robust microbial profiles have been
identified with this approach it's also
difficult to accurately identify a truly
healthy control population so the
definition of healthy and clinical
research is really just the exclusion of
a finite list
Jews in addition it's not always
epically possible to obtain that ideal
healthy control cohort so we continually
have to focus on the selection of the
most appropriate control cohort that's
available and simply keep these inherent
limitations in the comparison population
in mind it's also important to note that
our excellent exploration of the
microbiome reaches far beyond simply
determining bacterial composition
bacterial diversity has become a key
component of our comparisons with
decreases in bacterial diversity
diversity commonly associated with a
variety of disease states and Beyond
community structure it's really the
function of that community that remains
the most important piece so to briefly
tell you a little bit about how we do
what we do if you're not familiar with
microbiome techniques the first thing we
do is extract bacterial DNA from a
variety of different specimen types when
we're talking about characterization and
the gut microbiome that is most often a
stool specimen we then amplify the 16s
rRNA gene which is important because
it's present in all bacteria with the
16s rRNA gene we actually capitalize on
the alternating conserved in variable
regions within that gene thus allowing
us to utilize universal primers and
those conserved regions to theoretically
amplify any bacteria in the sample and
then sequence directly into the variable
regions that allows us to differentiate
between the various organisms we then
perform next-generation sequencing and
this can be done on a variety of
different sequencing platforms and
finally perform in-depth analysis to
potentially identify specific disease
signatures once we have these millions
of sequences we then quality filter and
group sequences into clusters that show
greater than 97 percent similarity
during this process were also able to
parse sequences back into their original
sample IDs based on unique barcode
sequences that were attached during the
amplification phase
we also take the representative
sequences from each of the clusters and
attempt to identify them to the lowest
taxonomic level possible and then move
on to conduct various comparisons be a
multiple bioinformatics approaches so
clusters of sequences that are greater
than 97% similar are referred to as
operational taxonomic units or ot use
and they roughly represent a bacterial
species beyond identification of
individual community members we also
evaluate the overall community
composition so for instance if you look
at the two boxes there in the center of
the slide you'll see that those
theoretical communities share the same
community members meaning the same five
different colors of bacteria are present
in both boxes but the community on the
right is heavily skewed toward the
purple bacteria and thus would represent
a community with decreased bacterial
diversity compared to the community on
the left and from there most of our
analyses involved comparisons within
sample subjects and groups as well as
between sample subjects and groups so
all of those basic techniques were also
employed in the human microbiome project
which of course was our effort to
characterize the healthy human adult
microbiome across 18 different body
sites the results of that study
confirmed our hypotheses in that
composition bacterial diversity and
relative abundance differ based on body
site we also quickly learned that the
microbiome continue to evolve throughout
the course of a lifetime with a variety
of factors affecting changes in the
microbial community this is actually a
terrific graphic to represent these
changes and for those of you that are
not as entrenched in microbiome research
it's worth pointing out that the change
is represented in this speaker are at a
very high level the phylum level in this
case many of the earlier publications in
microbiome science characterized
communities at these higher taxonomic
levels but with improvements in
sequencing technology and
dramatic strategies and database
curation we're now able to routinely
identify sequences to the genie genus
and sometimes even species level so to
put that in perspective you see here
bacteria at the kingdom level with
phylum just below that in order to
differentiate between ourselves and the
common house cat we'd have to move down
to the order level so again many of
these comparisons revealed very distinct
microbiomes in a very high level so once
we were able to routinely characterize
the healthy human microbiome the next
logical question was whether we could
use microbiome profiles to differentiate
between a healthy and a diseased state
and the answer of course was a
resounding yes especially with regards
to the gut microbiome and Gi based
diseases with the discovery of these
very micro biomes we then began to
question whether we could manipulate the
microbiome to restore a diseased state
to a healthy state and if that was
successful could those improvements
actually extend beyond the gut and
that's a question that we're still
working to answer I think it's worth
mentioning it at this point that we're
rapidly moving towards utilizing
microbiome characterization as a
clinical tool we don't envision this as
a standalone assay but rather a
companion diagnostic to reviewed in
light of routine clinical laboratory
testing and the complete clinical
picture these evaluations could be
highly useful in difficult to treat
cases as well as for longitudinal
monitoring during treatment we've seen
evidence of its utility and predicting
treatment success specifically in our
ability to assess pre-intervention
microbiomes where we've seen specific
profiles associated with responders to a
dietary intervention in pediatric
irritable bowel syndrome
similarly we believe that longitudinal
characterization of the microbiome could
yield important information related to
prognosis and we've utilized this
approach in the monitoring of our
pediatric recurrent C difficile patients
who are actually undergoing
fecal microbiota transplantation and
while many of our original studies
sought to capture a snapshot of the
microbial community in a single specimen
several of our current efforts have
actually moved towards exceeds based
approaches and one example of that is
the exploration of gut lung crosstalk in
patients with cystic fibrosis
so there's initial evidence that chronic
respiratory pathogens may in fact
colonize the gut prior to the first
acute lung infection thus serving as a
potential canary in a coal mine and
possibly allowing for better preparation
the lungs in anticipation of the
infection and of course our major topic
of this webinar the gut brain axis where
there is now mounting data supporting
the impact of microbial manipulation on
behavioral disorders including autism
spectrum disorder so all of us leaves us
with the proverbial chicken or the egg
question does it all start or end in the
gut so there are really three critical
considerations regarding crosstalk
between the gut and the brain and you
can see all of these depicted here in
this slide from nature but first is
related to the production of
neurotransmitters which of course 95
percent of the body's serotonin is
actually produced within the gut so the
gut microbiome also has the potential to
impact the immune system by eliciting
the production of cytokines that can
then of course influence neurophysiology
and finally the active metabolites
produced by specific up microbiomes can
affect activity at the blood-brain
barrier so these all represent key areas
of focus for us in regard to the
microbiome gut brain access in autism so
while the previous slide show you the
basics of the gut brain axis here you
see a far more intricate depiction of
the variety of interactions happening
along this axis the most important piece
to remember is of course communication
is bi-directional
and so changes on either end of the
this will induce changes throughout a
variety of pathways so there have been
many compelling studies regarding the
ability to affect behavior by microbial
manipulation specifically here you can
see many examples of this via antibiotic
probiotic administration in animal
models of both anxiety and depression
but as you can imagine clinical studies
in human subjects have been more sparse
but evidence is growing regarding the
impact of the microbiome on brain
function as illustrated by this study
where healthy women were given a
probiotic drink for just four weeks and
resting state MRI actually showed
alterations in the areas of the brain
responsible for central processing of
emotion and sensation but now I will
really focus more closely on the
microbiome gut brain access in autism we
know that there are multiple factors
contributing to gastrointestinal and
behavioral issues and autism spectrum
disorder and it's easy to envision a
never-ending cycle where a child with
sensory issues then withhold stool
leading to bloating and abdominal pain
if the child has difficulty
communicating then this could lead to
expressing their pain via self injurious
behavior and then the stress of that
situation could then cause even greater
gastrointestinal distress
now if you've tuned in to this webinar
you most likely are very familiar with
autism it's just worth noting that
although we've yet to identify a
singular cause of autism they remains a
set of core ASD symptoms that manifest
from a variety of potential causes
thereby suggesting that there could be
common broken pathways so our parents
have recorded gastrointestinal issues in
autism for years it's only been fairly
recently recognized as an actual
symptoms
symptom of autism spectrum disorder so
these symptoms can range from
constipation to diarrhea to even an
alternating phenotype and there are a
variety of different dietary
interventions that have been suggested
this brings me to a key problem in
August
research the vast majority of ASD
clinical research has utilized an
inclusion criteria that is simply a
diagnosis of ASD and we know that the
ASD population differs greatly from one
individual to the next and it is this
heterogeneity that makes it very
difficult to gauge whether treatments
are effective for specific symptoms of
autism spectrum disorder if we can
better subtype the larger ASD population
for example with multi omec profiles
that we are hoping to generate from our
research then treatment can be better
tailored to the challenges of each
individual on the spectrum in the
meantime it's still highly likely that
many of these failed interventions may
in fact be effective in a carefully
selected subset within the larger
spectrum we know that limited
communication can lead to poorly managed
abdominal pain which can in turn can
exacerbate behaviors such as self-injury
we hope to identify biomarkers that are
associated with the nominal pain in ASD
as well as identify specific
gastrointestinal and behavioral
phenotypes within autism in combination
with the microbiome and the table alone
these multi-omics profiles have
significant potential to be highly
useful in the diagnosis and in the
effective ongoing management and
treatment of autism so I want to start
at the beginning with what I see as the
birth of microbiome research and autism
it begins with a mom by the name of
Ellen Botti who saw significant
improvement in her child with autism
while on antibiotics she sought out
physicians and scientists to further
investigate this phenomenon and this led
to a small yet highly impactful trial
published over 15 years ago the greatest
strength of this trial was in the strict
inclusion criteria which effectively
selected a small group of children with
non syndromic autism who were more
severely affected and have associated GI
symptoms this intervention included
minute administration and vancomycin and
the majority of children displayed
significant improvements in their
symptoms while on antibiotics these
improvements did in fact wane following
this
discontinuation that binkham Ison but
nevertheless this study released that
the stage for an exciting area of future
research the Feingold group went on to
further characterize differences in the
gut bacteria in these children with
autism and identified several
Clostridium interest and then they went
on to develop a potential diagnosis for
the quantitation of these key bacteria
this work also included the discovery of
a novel species which was then named
clustered young bull ta AfterEllen bull
T thus forward 15 years and history
repeats itself a father in this case
John radhika's reported the same
improvement in his son with autism while
on a typical course of antibiotics and
again sought out physicians and
scientists who are willing to pursue
this area of research this effort
included mr. O doc is creating the N of
one autism research foundation which is
heavily focused on the functional
microbiome in autism spectrum disorder
luckily the role of the gut microbiome
and autism has gained significant
interest over the past three to four
years this is largely due in part to a
seminal paper published in 2013
describing the potential therapeutic
effect of a probiotic on the core
symptoms of autism this study utilized
the maternal immune activation model of
an Steen's is a model with huge
significance since it requires no
underlying genetics for the
manifestation of an ASD like phenotype
and the offspring of mothers where an
antimicrobial response is induced during
key developmental windows here they
documented gut dysbiosis increased
intestinal permeability and of course
symptoms associated with autism spectrum
disorder then with administration of a
probiotic in this case Bacteroides
fragilis they demonstrated correction of
GI dysfunction but what truly elevated
this study was the remarkable changes
they reported in behavior with global
improvements in all areas except for
social deficits in one recent study a
maternal fact that diet was utilized to
induce
and ASD like phenotype and offspring
with the use of another probiotic in
this case lactobacillus rotary social
games were observed along with the
restoration of oxytocin levels so while
the prior study focused on diet and the
mother
these next two studies focus on diets in
the offspring the ketogenic diet has
been employed in individuals with
epilepsy for many years and more
recently animal models of ASD have shown
potential benefit in the treatment of
core symptoms of autism with the BTB our
model improvements in sociability and
communication coincided with decreases
and self-directed behavior further
evaluation of the gut microbiome
revealed that the ketogenic diet
decreased total bacterial load along
with many other changes including a
decrease in costs trinium a very recent
publication also used the ketogenic diet
this time in the mi a mouse model and
again showed significant improvements in
sociability with decreases and soft
restricted behaviors so now we've talked
about antibiotics we talked about
probiotics and diets how about throwing
the whole kitchen sink in with fecal
microbiota transplantation
so Arizona State recently completed a
trial that utilized microbiota
transfer therapy as they referred to it
for the treatment of autism spectrum
disorder this trial recruited children
ages 7 to 17 and because they required
participants to fully consent to the
study protocol the study was huge for
the milder end of the autism spectrum
the findings of this study were just
published last month and the initial
results are very encouraging the
protocol included two weeks of Inka
Meissen followed by eight weeks of
either oral or rectal administration of
material and the participants were then
followed for eight additional weeks
after discontinuation of therapy and has
hoped significant improvements and
gastrointestinal symptoms were observed
in 16 of the 18 participants that
completed the protocol in addition they
were also able to capture global
improvements and
many of the core symptoms of autism
spectrum disorder and as they reported
no adverse events this certainly sets
the stage for future microbial therapy
trials in autism so to review we have
several options for microbial
manipulation whether it's a single
offense with antibiotics defense with
probiotics or a complete community
transplant via FM t above all it's
important to remember that our ultimate
goal is to restore function to the gut
microbiome and with that in mind we're
rapidly integrating metabolomics
into our studies of the gut microbiome
now to briefly review a few of the
previously published studies on the gut
microbiome in autism the first study to
utilize next-generation sequencing was
again Feingold's laboratory and this was
published in 2010 here they actually
stratified based on severity and a small
cohort but did in fact identify a
distinct microbiome in the ASD group
again to be a next-generation sequencing
for the first time in a subsequent study
by gundalia at all a larger cohort
failed to reveal differences associated
with ASD however there is a major
confounder and that they utilize
neurotypical siblings as controls and
it's likely that shared genetics and
environment would decrease the potential
resolution of these findings and with
this more recent publication from kang
at all we continue to have conflicting
results on the gut microbiome and ASD
with this study seeming to confirm
distinct microbial differences between
the ASD and nerds of the cohorts the
publication by and Angelis at all was
smaller in terms of total numbers and
excluded pedestrian tests no issues
however the inclusion of an intermediate
group with pdd-nos or pervasive
developmental disorder not otherwise
specified rather than just an ASD and
sibling group provides interesting
insight into those key differences in
the ASD group beyond other developmental
delays and then once again we have more
conflicting findings with yet another
study by son at all failing to find a
difference between the ASD group and
neurotypical siblings but again the
inclusion of an unrelated neurotypical
group could have yielded additional
intriguing data so to visually summarize
this is an excellent graphic published
in a recent review that illustrates the
range of findings regarding the gut
microbiome in autism and as you can see
these findings vary even at the phylum
level to summarize these studies in a
different way
here are the majority of studies that
have utilized next-generation sequencing
in the characterization of the gut
microbiome and autism spectrum disorder
now if you search PubMed you'll get
numerous results on the topic but the
majority are in fact reviews we're
guilty of it as well leaving only a
handful of studies to lay the groundwork
in this area each study of course has
limitations and when viewing this body
of research as a whole we began to
envision a study that would tackle as
many of those limitations as possible
and so two years ago we began a large
national study funded by Autism Speaks
and with additional recruitment sites at
UT Southwestern and Nationwide
Children's Hospital to characterize the
gut microbiome and the table alone in
children with autism to address some of
these prior limitations in the field we
required all the children participating
with us with ASD to have an 8oz
confirmed ASD diagnosis and on the flip
side of that we've also implemented a
screen to rule out the potential
diagnosis of ASD in both siblings and
unrelated marital controls we're
collecting extensive gastrointestinal
base data in the hopes of more accurate
stratification based on GI phenotype and
we've included neurotypical children
with functional GI disorders as well in
addition we've now instituted a three
month waiting period following any
antimicrobial use and of course
including antibiotics antihistamine
and antivirals ultimately we hope to
recruit close to 400 children and then
perform in depth multi omeka Nala's that
includes integration and
gastrointestinal behavioral and clinical
data with the gut microbiome amitab
alone so our multi omec profile includes
two gastrointestinal phenotype via
diaries they capture pain stooling
patterns and dietary intake as well as
evaluation based on 3criteria and the GI
severity index score we're also
obtaining multiple behavioral surveys as
well as a stool specimen for microbiome
and the table alone characterization as
I mentioned we're collecting a series of
behavioral surveys so we also hope to be
able to characterize participants based
on potential severity and problem
behaviors potentially associated with
gastrointestinal pain such as
self-injury with complete multi-omics
profiling we hope to provide further
insight into potential treatment options
and here we have an example of that
application we performed integrated
analysis of microbiome and the table
alone data on children with irritable
bowel syndrome who were undergoing a
dietary intervention in this case it was
the FODMAPs diet based on their pre diet
change stool specimen we could predict
responders to the diet by their multi
only profiles you can imagine how
impactful this could be in the autism
community where there are multiple
dietary interventions in use with
varying degrees of success similarly our
prior work and pediatric IBS identified
specific bacteria that were associated
with abdominal pain and the detection of
these key organisms could aid the
identification of abdominal pain and in
individuals with limited verbal
abilities so to briefly go back to prior
Studies on the gut microbiome and ASD
there was in fact a single study but
Williams at all that utilize
gastrointestinal biopsies and while the
number of subjects is small it's very
difficult to obtain these types of
specimen
and thus the findings remain highly
relevant especially in light of their
report of increased cluster D alleys in
the ASD group so in collaboration with
Kent Williams at Nationwide Children's
Hospital we're now publishing a second
study that's currently impressed of the
mucosal microbiome in autism spectrum
disorder we included a total of 35
children ages 3 to 18 who were
undergoing lower endoscopy we were
actually able to capture 6 neurotypical
children without functional GI disorders
because while their endoscopy was
clinically indicated the results
revealed simply benign rectal bleeding
we also had serum collected allowing for
the measurement of serotonin and
inflammatory cytokines so at the top
you'll see separation of groups via
principal component analysis with the
ASD group clearly separating from the
two neurotypical groups and as we dug
deeper into the composition of the
microbial communities we found that that
separation was driven most heavily by
differences in cluster et al ease and
this is a finding that echoed echoed
several of the prior studies in ASD as
you see here the top graphs to pick
those organisms that were significantly
different between the groups and you'll
notice several Clostridium as well as
LACMA crystal clustering and bull ta as
originally discovered by Sid Feingold
the graphs below display those organisms
that were most closely associated with
pain particularly in the ASD group and
again you see multiple cost realities
implicated so while we saw clear
separation between the ASD and
neurotypical groups thus identifying a
distinct microbe near immune profile in
ASD individuals with functional GI
disorders we were also able to
differentiate within the ASD group based
on the presence of abdominal pain in
addition many of these organisms were
associated with the serotonin pathway as
well as correlated with multiple
inflammatory cytokines so look at this
in more detail here you see the specific
organisms linked to ASD as well as to
organisms found an increased abundance
and me neurotypical with functional GI
disorder group you can also see the
potential connections to the serotonin
pathway as well as the many inflammatory
cytokines that are correlated with these
key cluster realities so the correlation
of multiple microbes with inflammatory
cytokines has proved very compelling as
increased cytokines have been previously
reported in non syndrome ik and/or a
regressive autism increased inflammatory
cytokines have also been associated with
the more severe end of the spectrum
including those with significant
communication the difficulties and
aberrant behaviors so this leads me
again to my central theme that accurate
subtyping an autism spectrum disorder
will lead to more robust clinical
research and ultimately more effective
treatment strategies and we hope that
our work in multi-omics Island in the
gut and ASD will contribute greatly to
that effort so the last piece I want to
cover involves a longitudinal case study
this specific case study was included as
part of our larger GI study in ASD but
here we take a single family who
collected daily stool specimens on the
ASD child while completing the two-week
protocol and associated diaries
questionnaires etc so in addition to a
neurotypical sibling we were also able
to compare against five unrelated age
and sex matched healthy nerve to the
whole controls here you can see clear
separation of all the specimens
collected from the child with ASD from
both the neurotypical sibling and other
unrelated neurotypical controls now let
me take an interesting aside here
thinking back to the original vancomycin
trial initiated by Alan bolte this case
study seems to fit their strict
inclusion criteria with normal
neuroanatomy non syndrome ik ASD the
manifestation of GI symptoms prior to an
ASD diagnosis and generally on the more
severe end of the spectrum I'd also like
to bring up melatonin at this point we
know this is widely used in the
SD community in the treatment of sleep
difficulties and again with varying
success so we're not actively tracking
participants who one take melatonin and
to experience significant improvement
and sleep patterns while on it
now why is melatonin relevant well as
you probably already know we're being
further down the serotonin pathway
brings you to melatonin so again we have
more compelling means to continue to
pursue a long nap microbiome gut brain
access but back to the case study here
you see the microbiome profiles across
the entire two weeks for the child with
ASD along with the single profile for
the neurotypical sibling at the far
right end this includes two samples from
day eight on the ASD child where there
was a significant change in stewing
pattern from morning to evening you may
also spot two areas within this graph
that appear to represent a change in the
microbiome and these two periods of time
actually coincided with gastrointestinal
episodes the first of which resulted in
abdominal pain as well as diarrhea and
the second of which caused abdominal
pain that didn't seem to result in a
change in stooling pattern now because
this child was in full-time behavioral
therapy we were actually able to capture
data on self-injurious behaviors as well
over the course of these two weeks and
this basically led us to observe the
trifecta of behavioral exacerbations
gastrointestinal symptoms and an altered
gut microbiome looking more closely at
the specific ASD microbiome we again saw
many bacteria previously reported in ASD
including Clostridium LTA and multiple
other clost realities that we observed
in the ASD cohort of the microsil
microbiome study that I just discussed
these organisms were also absent or
significantly decreased in the sibling
as well as in the unrelated neurotypical
controls so one unexpected finding was
the detection of Hamas parainfluenza
generally a respiratory pathogen but we
previously reported this organ is
in children with irritable bowel
syndrome however in this longitudinal
case study Hamas was interestingly
spikes during both of the GI episodes
with a more pronounced appearance in the
diarrhea episode and actually in the
diarrhea specimen we definitely confirm
the absence of any typical bacterial or
viral pathogen during those TGIF SOT I
running it through a clinical diagnostic
diagnostic GI panel and will continue to
evaluate the potential role of Halawa or
potentially other organisms during each
of those two gastrointestinal events
finally we've also performed global
metabolomic profiling on these samples
and have a multitude of interesting
findings that we're still working our
way through for example you see here
whom arginine appears to spike the
morning of the first GI episode but you
chiral glycine spikes later in the day
at the onset of the dire real episode we
also saw consistent decreases and
several fatty acids and the ASD samples
compared to the neurotypical controls
and neurotypical sibling that our work
continues in creating a comprehensive
data set for the exploration of the gut
microbiome and autism spectrum disorder
we are also currently recruiting for an
additional study supported by the N of
one ought ISM Research Foundation to
evaluate the effect effects of
antibiotics on both the gastrointestinal
and behavioral symptoms of autism
spectrum disorder this requires
participants to complete a baseline
study and then upon prescription of
antibiotics by their regularly treating
physicians they would provide another
stool specimen complete a series of
surveys over the next two weeks and then
provide a second stool specimen once
antibiotic therapy is discontinued while
we are not prescribing antibiotics this
trial will allow us to observe the
microbial and functional changes caused
by antibiotic
an autism spectrum disorder as well as
the impact on behavioral symptoms with
the hopes that these data will provide
direction on future therapeutic options
so to summarize there's clear evidence
of bi-directional communication across
the gut brain access via the central
init eric nervous systems and the gut
microbiome plays a key role in that
relationship we know that more large
well-controlled studies are needed and
we're currently working towards that
goal in the meantime we do think there's
significant utility and microbiome
characterization as a potential future
diagnostic and in individual case
studies including longitudinal samples
especially in difficult to treat cases
and whether that difficulty is on the
gastrointestinal or behavioral side and
finally while there are multiple new
promising areas of research regarding
the functional microbiome and immune
system in ASD microbial manipulation
remains a therapeutic option worth
exploring
[Music]
so with that I'll acknowledge my team
here within the Texas children
microbiome Center as well as my rep my
laboratory and medical metagenomics our
collaborators throughout the hospital as
well as Ken Williams at Nationwide
Children's and then our funding support
from both the end of one autism Research
Foundation and autism Speaks and now I'm
happy to take any questions
[Music]
thank you dr. Luna for your informative
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and dr. Luna will interest many
questions as time permits so without
hesitation let's jump in to our Q&A
portion dr. Luna our first question of
the day asks can specialized diets
improve symptoms associated with
optimism so in terms of specialized
diets we know there have been prior
trials that have failed to identify a
significant improvement in symptoms
while on something like the gluten-free
casein-free diet but as I mentioned
during the presentation without the
ability to effectively subtype within
the larger spectrum of autism it's
completely unknown as to whether these
diets may have significant impact on
specific individuals with autism so with
that we basically look to each family
and each individual with autism to
perform their own evidence based
medicine trial there na-1 trial to
determine whether specific elimination
diets or changes in the diet do elicit
positive benefits in their child with
autism so we absolutely think there's
huge potential in a variety of
specialized diets and you just need to
try out several with your child and try
to have an unbiased way to track changes
in their behavior and potential
improvements and move on from there
[Music]
so this is a question that we get quite
frequently in the initial days of our
study we were trying to stick to the
three recruitment sites but as we've
expanded we are now able to recruit
nationally both for the larger autism GI
multi-omics Eiling study and for the
specific antibiotics study we've now I
think perfected our ability to ship
materials back and forth to families so
you will be able to participate remotely
and again both of those trials are still
open for participants and you're welcome
to contact me if you're interested in
participating in either of those studies
thank you dr. Liana our third question
of the day asks should all children with
ASD be evaluated by a gastroenterologist
so this is something that we've
addressed quite a bit within our own
internal group of autism researchers
here there are many indications for
individuals with autism to see a
gastroenterologist and these indications
are not always obvious to caregivers we
definitely think it's worth at least
having an initial visit with the
gastroenterologist to discuss potential
issues one of the most common symptoms
in ASD is constipation and functional
constipation and this could definitely
be contributing to potential domina pain
again a reported abdominal pain that
could be exacerbating severe behaviors
in that child with ASD so we definitely
think it's worth at least an initial
constant consultation with the
gastroenterologist knowing how prevalent
many of these GI issues are within that
pediatric asd population
[Music]
thank you dr. Luna thank you for your
presentation it doesn't apparent we have
any additional questions at the moment
so I would like to thank you again for
your presentation do you have any final
comments that you would like to leave us
with today thanks Christina
I just like to thank you for the
opportunity to present this research
we're very excited about the direction
the field is moving and we're doing our
best with these larger studies to
continue to contribute to that body of
knowledge and again if you're interested
in participating in any of these studies
you're more than welcome to contact me
my email is RA luna ra o u na @ b CM edu
so Baylor College of Medicine edu and
once again thank you for listening once
again thank you for your time I like to
thank the audience as well
for joining us today and thank lab
groups for its pace educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through may 2017 lab routes will alert
you via email when it is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live events this is
Christina with lab rooms wishing you a
great day we hope to see you here again
soon at lab roots dot-com
goodbye